bonjour j'ai lu ball ange bonjour
fallait rivières le premier ministre
polonais n'en a pas démordu hier à la
tribune du parlement européen il a
maintenu que le droit polonais devait
primer sur le droit européen comme l'a
récemment affirmé le tribunal
constitutionnel polonais il a également
dénoncé le chantage des institutions
européennes contre son pays qu'elle doit
être selon vous la réponse de l'union
européenne
d'abord le premier ministre polonais il
n'a pas démordu personnes attendent et
qui débordent on savait bien qu'il
allait persévérer dans sa voix je crois
qu'il faut d'abord
dénoncé enfin démontrer plus tôt
l'incongruité du système ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que c'est pas la
question de savoir si le droit
communautaire est supérieure ou
inférieure au droit national en réalité
si le droit communautaire n'est pas
supérieur au droit national il n'y a
plus de droit communautaire quand vous
faites qu'est ce que c'est le droit
communautaire c'est le droit du contrat
c'est à dire c'est 27 pays qui décident
ensemble de faire quelque chose si après
que la décision est prise
que la directive est lancé c'était à
chacun revient chez soi et du moment y
at elle est à l'aspect qui ne
m'intéresse pas c'est comme si vous
passiez un faisait un bail ou passiez ou
signé un bail avec votre corps pour
avoir un appartement quand vous revenez
chez vous quand dix ans me coûte s-bahn
il est très bien je fais simplement
diminuer le loyer par deux il est
évident qu'il n'y aurait plus de bail il
n'y aurait plus donc le problème mais a
contrario pour pour reprendre l'image de
l'immobilier est ce qu'on n'est pas
passé dans une situation où le syndic de
copropriété ne gère plus seulement les
parties communes mais vient aussi dans
les appartements dire je veux que papier
pastel couleur ou la baignoire de tels
cas alors c'est ça on peut on peut donc
on peut discuter la particularité c'est
que l'europe c'est du droit dérivé comme
on dit c'est à dire c'est pas simplement
à un traité c'est un traité qui a mis au
point un mécanisme procédurales très
démocratique d'ailleurs avec les états
au sein du conseil avec le parlement
avec la cour de justice pour produire
des règles communes alors si ray le
commune fonctionne un juge et ses juges
c'est la cour de justice
j'en rappelle que la cour de justice est
composé de juges désignés par les états
membres se sont pas des juges qui
surgissent de nulle part ce sont des
juges que les états membres se sont mis
d'accord alors là ou
là où il ya un problème il se pose pas
du tout aux propos de la faire il ya
deux problèmes à propos de ça le premier
c'est que la loi coin la constitution
d'un pays c'est quelque chose même si
vous dites le droit communautaire ses
supérieurs le bon sens résiste en disant
non la constitution c'est la loi
fondamentale d'un état c'est bien qu on
fait toujours attention à éviter de
mettre en contradiction le traité chaque
fois qu'on a fait un traité nouveau
donnant une compétence nouvelle à
l'union on a consulté conseil
constitutionnel pour savoir en france
pour savoir si ça collait et le conseil
de sun zi la plupart des temps il faut
changer l aspect de la constitution ce
qu'on a fait et si on n'avait pas fait
on apprendrait pas signé que le premier
ministre polonais a aussi évoqué
l'élargissement des compétences qui
conduirait son pays à devoir se
soumettre à un droit et à des
engagements qu'il n'avait pas pris oui
alors l'union européenne a de quoi
parle-t-il quand c'est là où il est
vraiment tout à fait en faute s'est il
s'agit pas simplement comme les
britanniques qui disait on conteste
telle ou telle décision il s'agit du
coeur de la machine c'est à dire que
l'adhésion à l'union européenne le
traité l'union européenne c'est un
accord sont des principes démocratiques
sont le respect de l'état de droit sur
les libertés fondamentales sur le
pluralisme sur la démocratie
représentative
or là nous sommes en phase en pologne
d'une tentative extrêmement puissante de
remise en cause des libertés
fondamentales et notamment la cour
constitutionnelle ça n'est pas une cour
constitutionnelle ce sont des juges aux
ordres du gouvernement de varsovie il ya
eu des tas de mesures à 2000 manière
pour prendre le contrôle politique par
le gouvernement de ses juges donc nous
sommes dans une remise en cause de
l'état de droit en pologne autant et et
ça nous concerne parce que voyez vous
l'union européenne ça fonctionne avec
des états si vous ne respectez pas la
démocratie en pologne vous ne respectez
pas la démocratie dans l'union
européenne parce que vous avez des
polonais au parlement européen parce que
vous avez les polonais au conseil des
ministres parce que vous avez polonais
comme juge à la cour de justice ou à la
cour des comptes est donc en réalité
derrière cette affaire c'est le font
seulement même de l'union telle que nous
l'avons construite démocratiquement
contrairement à ce qui est dit très très
respectueuse du droit qui est en cause
donc il ya vraiment péril en la demeure
c'est pas nous c'est pas un petit abus
de pouvoir est en cause c'est le coeur
même de l'organisation démocratique de
l'union européenne ne peut pas accepter
car certain nombre d'états fonctionne
sur un mode de ce qu'on appelle
maintenant paul un mot un peu un peu
obscur mais mais quand même assez
éclairant une démocrature lequel rupture
rapidement est ce que j'aurai qu'on
aborde un ou deux autres sujets mais est
ce que là la grande bretagne a ouvert
une brèche escale à dédramatiser
finalement la sortie de l'union
européenne
n'ont en tout cas les polonais revue
nature ont pas de sortir l'union
européenne et dans les airs c'est tout
et l'union européenne n'envisage pas de
d'exclure
on a des en tout cas ça la situation
n'est pas tolérable on ne peut pas on ne
peut pas être membre du club et ne pas
respecter les principes fondamentaux du
club il ya plusieurs et madame van dalen
a évoqué plusieurs possibilités la plus
simple et la plus expérience aujourd'hui
c'est en tout cas de bloquer les fonds
parce que demandent par exemple le
premier ministre néerlandais de bloquer
les fonds du plan de relance andréanais
generation à partir du moment où il ya
des nous avons des instruments
juridiques pour ça en disant si les cas
droit n'est pas respecté en pologne donc
si le bon fonctionnement
le bol de l'argent public européen n'est
pas assurée on bloque ça se serait vu
une absurdité et les polonais en sont
conscients je connais bien la pologne
beaucoup participé
à l'adhésion à l'introduction de la
pologne quand j'étais parlementaire
européen je peux vous dire que le
mouvement pro européens en pologne est
beaucoup plus fort que dans d'autres
pays est sans doute plus fort qu'en
france mais on a un gouvernement qui est
très obscurantiste et qui vraiment à vis
à vis des règles démocratiques eu une
attitude très profondément négative en
un mot on aurait une minute les prix de
l'énergie ont augmenté dans des
proportions un peu folle ces derniers
mois le gouvernement doit annoncer avant
la fin de la semaine des mesures pour
faire face notamment à la flambée des
prix des carburants est ce qu'il ya pour
vous dans cette situation les ferments
d'une nouvelle crise sociale un peu à la
manière de cette bd je ne sais pas si
c'est celle des gilets jaunes mais je
crois d'une façon générale que tout ce
qu'on fait sur le plan de l'adaptation
climatique de de l'adaptation à eau aux
pénuries et quelque chose de pécs très
moment extrêmement révolutionnaire je
pense que nous ne pourrons pas abordé
les transitions que nous devons mener au
cours des années proches au cours des
années à venir nous ne pourrons pas
l'aborder sans avoir à très solide
bouclier social alors maintenant il
s'agit d'en discuter de discuter de la
consistance la structure de ce bouclier
mais il va y avoir des idées des
embardées dans tous les domaines qui
vont effectivement atteindre les gens
dans leur pouvoir d'achat est plutôt
ceux qui n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent
donc là c'est une vraie préoccupation la
préoccupation sociale elle sera centrale
au cours des dix prochaines années merci
jean louis bourlanges bonne journée